now i wouldn't normally do this to you
but it is particularly relevant based on
what's happened over the last week in
the shootings the day after speaking at
the nra in houston texas and dancing on
stage at the end of his speech donald
trump flew to wyoming and gave a
campaign speech in wyoming for the
republican challenger to liz cheney liz
cheney now for the maga cult is an enemy
because she acknowledges that donald
trump really lost the election um they
want to remove her they're primarying
her she's doing very well in the polls
she'll probably win
but trump flying up there to campaign
for it's funny
when trump campaigns for someone that
person is almost completely irrelevant i
don't even remember the woman's name i
think it's ed hageman or something like
that
and um this trump's brain appeared to
just break it it's it his brain is
broken it's not functioning in this clip
trump explains
how
his kaffifi tweed i call it cobb feffe
was so big he's like bragging about the
fact
that a tweet that was literal nonsense
and unintelligible by a president which
has never been explained he's bragging
how it was his most popular tweet ever
this
the guy's brain is not functioning
i put out like this tweet i think it was
like on a saturday morning and i saw
something on television and i said
i believe obama
spied
on my campaign
okay
no i didn't think it was that big a deal
you know you put it
on a ball
three minutes later i get a call like my
phone goes crazy
sir
sir did you just say that
president obama
spied in your campaign yeah what's the
big deal
sir
the wires are burning up i said really
after koffe it was the single biggest
tweet i ever did kofi was bigger
but he's ignoring the fact that the
reason it was big is because it was a
red flag globally that the president has
lost his marbles and his brain is broken
after kofi which was world's number one
it was the biggest tweet i ever did and
i thought it was just going to be like
routine you know i'm throwing it out but
that's what i thought that's what i
heard and you know why it was such a big
deal because
we caught them and they realized that we
caught them
and it became a monster now understand
that uh obama was not caught spying on
trump's campaign none of this makes any
sense but trump is now bragging about
kofi
this is not a functioning brain it's not
a functioning brain trump then says that
the way to stop the war in ukraine
is to take out the windmills now he
means wind farms he uses the term
windmills he also wrongly claims the
russian ruble is now at an all-time high
bad as they're doing and as much as
they're spending the ruble
is at an all-time high because they're
taking in so
much money why you want to stop the war
drive down the price
of oil drive down the price of energy
you want to stop it stop with the
windmills
that kill all your birds and destroy
your environment yeah they're called
wind farms and they don't destroy the
environment and they kill fewer birds
than the oil and gas industry but more
importantly trump says the ruble is at
an all-time high
uh the ruble is actually close to an
all-time low we're putting the price
chart up on the screen and as you can
see the ruble is actually very low now
revisionist history donald trump is now
calling it a so-called insurrection and
he is saying the idea that it was an
insurrection on january 6
is as fake as the russia probe which by
the way was very very real revision is
history and the crowd accepts it now you
look at the so-called word insurrection
january 6 what a lot of crap what a lot
of crap
and most of this country knows it and
you know who else knows that the
democrats it's another con job just like
russia russia russia this was made up
by hillary clinton and the democrats
a total
fake story now i don't know if he's
saying there that the russia story was
fake
or that the insurrection story is fake
and made up by hillary clinton he thinks
both are fake for sure and then bringing
out all of the greatest hits trump also
lying about the price of gas 87
per gallon gasoline think of that now
it's going to close to nine dollars
today
that's 87.
nine dollars and of course all you have
to do is look at the official gas prices
and you see that when trump left office
it wasn't a dollar eighty-seven it was
two dollars and 42 cents and now it's
four dollars and 21 cents it's much
higher no doubt nobody denies that it is
not nine dollars so another absolutely
despicable event uh just a little bonus
clip here trump uh struggling to
pronounce the word conservative we're
going to
vote out this atrocious rhino
and we're going to replace her with a
conservative warrior from a place called
wyoming yeah it doesn't seem as though
that's going to happen liz cheney is
doing quite well i have i'm not a fan of
liz cheney's i'm just telling you what
it looks like it looks like this will
almost certainly
be another loss in donald trump's
endorsement record the man's brain is
broken my friends and we'll have these
clips on our instagram at david pakman
show one of our sponsors is little spoon
your one stop shop for easy healthy
meals and snacks for your baby toddler
or big kid
if you're a parent of any age child
little spoon makes healthy meal times
simpler and it saves you hours at a very
reasonable price little spoon makes
everything fresh just like homemade but
it's delivered to your door and ready in
seconds pop it in the fridge or freezer
and it is ready when you are they have
100 organic cold pressed baby food for
every eating stage awesome food for
toddlers and for kids they even just
launched a new line of on-the-go
smoothies that kids love everything is
nutritionally balanced no junk food but
it is kid approved it's food that
they'll actually eat and enjoy and you
can't beat the prices with kids meals
under five dollars baby food and
smoothie snacks under three dollars
little spoon is giving my audience 50
off your first order go to
littlespoon.com and use the code pacman
the link is down below